there's so many reasons why i do what i
do
i love surfing and i love helping people
i think if everybody found what they
loved to do what they were designed to
do and use that gift to help others this
world would look so different
my name is lambert lowe and i'm a surf
instructor
i was living in hawaii living the dream
teaching surfing to billionaires and
celebrities
at the end of the day something was
missing and i knew in my heart that i
needed to come back to where it all
started
i grew up in california
the ocean was where i felt the most
connected
i came back and started a non-profit
called the mix academy
[Music]
one of the things that come out of the
mix academy is this surf school
and i brought that gift of surfing here
with some of the people that need the
most smiles push up from the side stand
up
my current class consists of a refugee
from north korea
nathan a nine-year-old who's visually
impaired and shannon a veteran going
through alcoholism
[Music]
school of the misfits is a place where
you can belong on land everyone looks at
us a little differently but when you're
in the water the water washes all that
off
surfing like life is full of ups and
downs there's waves that are coming
and you can't stop that from coming
pain's gonna come what you can't control
is yourself and how you're gonna react
you can choose to paddle for it embrace
it adapt to it and enjoy the ride or
this wave is going to come and it's
going to knock you out and it's going to
wipe you out
catching a wave is a great feeling
helping others catch their first wave is
a greater feeling
to watch that smile just ear to ear and
knowing that man that's gonna change
someone's life
[Music]
you